i'm a big fan of your work as you know
congrats on this series it's so it's so
good um thank you
before i get into that i do like to
throw a few curve balls at the beginning
um
it's painless i promise if you if
someone has actually never seen anything
you've done before what is the first
thing they should watch and why
ah that's a real curveball i suppose i
feel that you know it would be it would
actually be either rocket man or or this
purely because i feel that they were
most they were the one i
the they were the most complex roles
i've played so i feel the most
creative reward from those two roles so
either rocket man or this
i don't i don't know which
um you've worked with some very talented
directors um is directing something
you're interested in or is it something
where you you know i guess let me start
with that or stop with that yes
absolutely it is it's something that i
think i would have to feel incredibly
certain of
my ability to tell the story well and
sometimes i feel like i haven't consumed
enough
of my of you know i'm not
i haven't so far seen enough movies and
tv shows and understood
the filmmaking process enough to be able
to take that leap but i i really think i
will do it at some point i'd love to
have a go at a short film or something
um being a producer on this is kind of a
first tentative step into trying to
learn more about
what happens in the background as well
as just the acting you know
do you find yourself now when you're
filming on something looking at the lens
being used and asking why are you using
this
of course yeah of course that's
happening more and more and
you know particularly because i feel
like the more i go on the more i feel
like
the camera there's a
there's a relationship with the camera
and the camera changes depending on
the lens how it's being used you know
how dynamic it is and and that so of
course i'm developing more and more of
an interest in all of that yes i'm sure
after rocket man you were sent a ton of
scripts and this is the first thing i
believe that you took on yeah um and so
what was it did you was there almost
another project that you agreed to or
was this the first thing that hit you
that said i need to do this yeah i think
i felt that
you know
i was really lucky with rocketman and it
was it was
it really i think
made people more aware of me and
slightly changed
you know it just felt a bit more grown
up i think as a role than the things i'd
done before as brilliant as i was as
happy as i was to have those
opportunities
um
and this
the when this came along i just felt it
was undeniable it was it was such a
compelling read it was so sophisticated
and it had a rare blend of being
something that i felt both had
incredible artistic merit and
sophistication to it but could
conceivably have
commercial broad appeal as well and i
think when something comes along and it
has both of those things that's really
thrilling because you think wow i could
have an incredible creative experience
here and also find a really wide
audience and that is that's the sweet
spot i love dennis's writing um
he's so good with words what is it like
or what was it like collaborating with
him and reading you know what i mean
because he's so talented
yeah i mean i always think you know
with somebody like dennis who is you
know in that
in that you know in the big leagues
i i mean
it's just like it's you know if acting
is turning up to a fight it's like being
given all the best weapons you know you
just got all these you've got these
incredible tools
and um
dennis is the kind of writing where
you don't just you you want to speak it
as you're reading it if you're if you're
if you're being presented with an offer
to play one of your characters because
the words are so great they just feel
like they're just so great you know and
it's so lean dennis's writing is in no
way fatty or
it's just um yeah and it's so active as
well you know it's it's
language being used rather than just
describing um
so yeah i loved working with him he's a
great great guy and um yeah i'd kill to
do it again actually it's an amazing
experience like everyone else i am a
huge fan of ray liotta you can look at
the shirt um
i i think he's so incredible in this
i've seen all six episodes he's so good
in this role um what was it like
actually working with him because he he
is just delivering in this uh in this
role he is yeah i think he's one of one
of
if not my favorite performance of his um
he just i i you know i think ray was
brought a huge level of commitment to
everything he did but when he stepped on
the set to to
to film the scenes with me
you know about a year ago
he was um
he was very very kind of charged and
ready and really
kind of just consumed by the role you
know he was he it was it was striking it
was it was actually difficult at times
to know if he
was kind of slightly
channeling that role of big jim
throughout the day he certainly
maintained the quality of energy of the
parts the frailty of the role the
vulnerability of the role
um
and i loved working with him i felt an
instantaneous connection with him i felt
an incredible
uh warmth and openness from him um
but he also had that raeliata
edge
just doesn't leave him you know you
believe that big jim
has
you know there were times
you know he where he we would discuss
things to do with the role and the
situation and he would
talk about what my character was going
through and he'd get
really angry about it because he was
feeling big jim's
protectiveness you know and he'd have
conversations with
with whichever you know of our directors
was was uh was shooting at the time and
and um
and he'd become kind of fired up about
the fact that you know
just the guards things like that
conversations that he's happening with
the guards on stage he gets to get
incredibly angry because
he felt something of the protectiveness
of the character and and i think that's
the kind of actor he was you know he had
an incredible capacity for empathy and
and understanding and and really brought
all of himself to the role what are you
actually most looking forward to like
it's a little generic but what are you
most looking forward to like audiences
seeing in the series because there's so
many different things about this i think
yeah for sure i mean
ray's performance is obviously one of
the things that i i think is very
there's a
sort of
melancholy obviously because ray is no
longer with us but it's an incredible i
think
kind of epitaph
for him as a as an actor because it's
it's a beautiful performance so i am
very excited for people to see
his work because it's it's second to
none
and then i you know i also just think
it's what dennis has crafted is a show
that is
it's kind of
you know even even
even for me
i can't be objective about it because
i'm the lead actor
but i know i know that it's engaging
from start to finish it's abs it's
gripping television dennis has put
something together that is really really
really really well made and i'm just
excited for people to
start the ride because you know as was
the case with you i think once you're on
it it's hard to get off and
you know i'm i'm really really excited
for people to to go through that
experience it's i'm so i'm super proud
of it
uh what are you getting ready to film
this year what projects are on your
horizon
there is a very there's i i i it's so
lame i wish i wish i could tell you
about it but i'm pretend it's looking
likely that i'll be filming something in
the last quarter of this year
very very very different um
but um
that will probably require me
you know
starting to think about getting back in
shape and all that stuff so um is it
called is it called kingsman
no it's not it's not that's that's not
that unfortunately that's further back
in the pipeline you've got to ask
matthew about that i'm sure you'll speak
to him before too long but um
trying to get information out of that
guy's like trying to get blood from a
stone so well
i'm i'm familiar
oh i i got a rap i'm just going to say
i'm uh matthew told me a lot about
tetris oh yeah and that sounds bonkers
and cool and i can't wait thanks man
it's really fun super different tonally
to this but
it's come together really well i'm
really excited about it yeah i can't
wait listen i wish you nothing but the
best amount of time just gonna say um
have a fantastic day man thank you so
much thank you it's always nice speaking
with you mate take care